jihadi messages on social media
including two hours before his attack
early reports indicated that the shooter
arrived at the site accompanied by other
Saudi cadets who took video during the
attack
these reports turned out not to be
accurate the shooter arrived by himself
the other Saudi cadets happen to be in
the area and after the attack began they
took some videos of the resulting
commotion around the building they fully
cooperated in the investigation as did
all other Saudi cadets who were
interviewed by the FBI at the base and
in other bases around the country after
al Sam Rani entered the building and
cased the facility he proceeded to walk
around shooting down his unarmed victims
in cold blood during and after this
heinous attack there were many specific
acts of courage and I want to draw a
special attention to two US Marines
gunnery sergeant Ryan Maisel and Staff
Sergeant Samuel Mullins they were
outside the building when they heard the
gunfire and although unarmed they ran
into the building to confront the
shooter their only weapon was a fire
extinguisher that they pulled off the
wall as they ran toward the gunfire
although they were unable to engage the
shooter they helped save many lives by
giving CPR and other urgent medical aid
to the victims they would also like to
mention the heroic acts of Navy airman
Ryan Blackwell the shooter shot airman
blackwell five times yet he managed to
jump on top of a fellow sailor to keep
her from being shot and then assisted
other students and helped them escape
all while taking fire from the shooter
Ryan Blackwell's heroic act save
countless lives that day and were
grateful to the for the bravery of the
base personnel and the local law
enforcement responders
who initially arrived at the scene and
engaged the shooter I would also like to
address the cooperation of the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia gave complete and total support
to our counter as terrorism
investigation they ordered all Saudi
trainees to fully cooperate this
assistance was critical to helping the
FBI determine whether anyone assisted
the shooter in these attacks while there
is no evidence of assistance or pre
knowledge of the attack by other members
of the Saudi military or any other
foreign nationals who were training in
the United States we did learn of
derogatory material possessed by 21
members of the Saudi military who were
training in the United States 17 had
social media containing some jihadi or
anti-american content however there was
no evidence of any affiliation or
involvement with any terrorist activity
or group 15 individuals including some
of the 17 I just mentioned so there is
overlap had some kind of contact with
child pornography while one of these
individuals had a significant number of
such images all the rest had one or two
images in most cases posted in a chat
room by some other person or received
over social media the relevant US
Attorneys offices independently reviewed
each of the 21 cases involving
derogatory information and determined
that none of them would in the normal
course result in federal prosecution
however the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
determined that this material
demonstrated conduct unbecoming an
officer in the Royal Saudi Air Force and
in the Royal Navy and the 21 cadets have
been disenrolled from their training
curriculum in the US military and will
be returning to Saudi Arabia late
today the kingdom has assured me that it
will review each of these cases under
their Code of Military Justice and their
Criminal Code the Kingdom has also
agreed that we will have full access to
any wheel anyone we want to interview in
Saudi Arabia and any documents relevant
to our investigation indeed they have
already been providing documents further
the kingdom has assured us that if we
later decide to charge any of those
being sent back to Saudi Arabia in
connection with his counterterrorism
investigation they will be returned for
trial
we appreciate the kingdom's cooperation
in this case finally I want to address
an issue regarding the shooters phones
the shooter possessed to Apple iPhones
seen here on on the posters within one
day of the shooting the FBI sought and
received court authorization based on
probable cause to search both phones in
an effort to run down all leads and
figure out with whom the shooter had
been communicating during the gunfight
with the first responders the shooter
disengaged long enough to place one of
his phones on the floor and shoot a
single round into the device it also
appears the other phone was damaged our
experts at the FBI crime lab were able
to fix both damaged phones so that they
are operational however both phones are
engineered to make it virtually
impossible to unlock without the
password it is very important for us to
know with whom and about what the
shooter was communicating before he died
we have asked Apple for their help in
unlocking the shooters phones so far
Apple has not given any substantive
assistance this situation perfectly
illustrates why it is critical that the
public be able to get access to digital
evidence
once it has obtained a court order based
on probable cause we call on Apple and
other technology companies to help us
find a solution so that we can bet
protect the lives of American people and
prevent future attacks with that I will
turn things over to the Deputy Director
of the FBI
Dave Bowditch good afternoon everyone
I'd like to offer a brief overview of
our investigation into this particular
attack as you can imagine this has been
a large and incredibly complex
investigation with dozens of
investigative entities being involved
let me start by what we've done so far
since the beginning of this
investigation the FBI and our partners
have been united in one goal to
determine if the shooter acted alone or
if anyone helped him to explain the
scope of the investigation so far we've
interviewed more than 500 people with
witnesses base personnel and the
shooters friends classmates and
associates even today we continue to run
down any new leads in an effort to find
as many answers as possible for the
victims and their families for more than
a month now this has been an
around-the-clock investigation as the
Attorney General mentioned this occurred
on December 6th that is going into a
holiday season where our folks work 24/7
as necessary throughout the holidays
this investigation involved hundreds of
special agents from the FBI intelligence
analysts and professional experts from
around the country in addition to our
counterparts which I will talk to you
about in just a minute we've employed
dozens of surveillance teams and
executed served or obtained numerous
search warrants subpoenas court orders
an emergency disclosure requests we've
also collected more than 42 terabytes of
data digital media in an effort to
exploit that date and the effort to
exploit that data continues to this day
while we're still searching for more
information so far we have not
identified any co-conspirators any
evidence that the shooter acted with
anyone
else for that he was inspired by any one
specific group social media attributed
to the shooter suggest that he harbored
anti US military and anti-israel
sentiments and that he thought violence
was necessary to defend Muslim countries
in addition just prior to the attack a
statement was posted to his social media
accounts which had many parts of Anwar
Awlaki Anwar al-awlaki
a now deceased senior leader of al-qaeda
in the Arabian Peninsula it had many
many messages that were very similar to
Anwar Awlaki and during the attack the
shooter fired shots at pictures of the
current US president and a former US
president and a witness at the scene
recounted that he made statements
critical of American military actions
overseas regarding the attack I can now
share that the shooting lasted
approximately 15 minutes naval security
forces and the escapists acuity forces
engaged the shooter approximately eight
minutes after the shooting began and
we've determined that he was ultimately
killed by law enforcement officers who
responded very bravely that day at the
crime scene we found a semi-automatic
handgun with an extended magazine
several ammunition magazines and
approximately 180 rounds of ammunition
as announced previously the ATF
identified the shooters weapon as having
been lawfully purchased in july 2019 in
the state of florida it was purchased
under a hunting license exception this
exception allows non-immigrant visa
holders who otherwise are not permitted
to buy firearms or ammunition to
purchase them if they have a valid state
issued hunting license permit or other
required documentation the partnerships
are crucial in any case like this
unfortunately we have way too many cases
like this but I do want to take a moment
to thank our other partners in this
investigation to include other faiths
federal state and local agency partners
for their hard work and they include the
Naval Criminal Investigative Service the
Air Force Office of Special
Investigations the ATF the Homeland
Security Investigations and the Florida
Department of Law Enforcement I
especially want to bread to recognize
the brave naval security forces Forces
personnel who responded to the initial
call for help as well as the Escambia
County sheriff's deputies who also
responded and very bravely ran in to
face down danger they did their jobs
that day and they did them well those
heroes save lives that day we do believe
that very firmly and three of them paid
a price for it three of them were
wounded that day all three are
recovering but they paid a price for it
that day I'm also grateful to our FBI
Jacksonville field office and its
personnel and a host of supporting FBI
headquarters personnel and resources
from other field office as you can
imagine when you have a significant
crisis investigation like this we will
surge resources from throughout the
country and this case was no different
finally I want to echo the Attorney
General's point about the challenge that
law enforcement faces from default
user-controlled
encryption the FBI continues to work
with our private sector partners to find
the right solution for accessing the
digital evidence we need to stop
criminals and terrorists alike we're not
trying to weaken encryption to be clear
and after all data security is a central
part of our mission but even with a
court order to date we cannot access the
contents of the two phones that the
Attorney General referenced previously
in this investigation and countless
devices and other investigations we want
to work together with the private sector
companies so that we can law
fully access the evidence and
information we need to keep our country
and its citizens safe this is not a
problem that only the federal government
has this is a problem that affects our
state and local partners as well as many
of our international partners and we
talked about this on a daily basis we
need to continue to work together
between public and private sector to
find a solution to this very challenging
problem thank you Mike none of the other
students are facing federal charges if
you've identified them possessing child
pornography or sharing jihadist
analogies you mean none of the other of
the twenty-one that we're talking about
well as far as the ideological social
media it was not enough to trigger a
violation of the federal statute and the
the other cases were reviewed by the US
Attorney's Office under the standards
they would use for anybody else and they
would not they were not sufficient to
trigger a federal prosecution you
identified a purpose for the trip to New
York or you believe that he may have
been scouting other locations for
another possible attack we have not what
I will tell you is there were other
Saudi students throughout the country it
is not unusual for them to travel we did
extensively back vet the places they
went and this was not an unusual
activity Sadie I have two questions one
is on topic and maybe you can answer
this but I was wondering if the FBI had
ever been called to the base previously
for an investigation into extremism or
that there had been reports that many
other
sort of terrorist behaviour you know
jadi behavior previously to the shooting
know the FBI and Jacksonville has not
been called to the Navy base for any of
those extremist views or anything like
that on Friday the FBI director had
released had told the by support some
changes in the way agents are going to
seek twice of warrants going forward has
the Justice Department proposed any
other changes to the way that the FBI
should open counterintelligence
investigations of political campaigns or
because about anything you're
considering in that friend
well we're considering you know a number
of additional things Chris ray and I
have discussed a number of possibilities
one of the things that we have agreed on
is that the opening of a
counterintelligence investigation of a
presidential campaign would be something
that the director of the FBI would have
to sign off on and the Attorney General
would have to sign off on after the San
Bernardino problem getting into the
phone of one of the gunmen there the
Justice Department took Apple to court
are you considering doing that in this
case I'm not going to comment on that
Deven a question for the deputy director
if I may
we're the FBI's technical experts on
cell phones consulted in the letter that
was sent to Apple and do they agree with
sending that letter to Apple I don't
know everyone who put on put eyes on
that but yes the general counsel would
have involved them as a matter of course
I don't know the answer Evan on the
issue of the striking in Iran the
Iranian general the White House's told
us that the Justice Department was
consulted before the decision was made
to do this
can you explain to people in Congress
including conservatives who have
questions about whether or not this was
a constitutional strike given the fact
that the Constitution gives Congress the
right to declare war and in this case
obviously this is an act of war and they
were not consulted well the Department
of Justice was consulted and frankly you
know I don't think it was a close it was
a close call I believe that the the
president clearly had the authority to
act as he did on numerous different
bases you know we had a situation where
the Iranians had already embarked on a
series of escalating escalating violent
action taken against our allies taken
against American people our troops with
the avowed purpose of driving us out of
the the Middle East they had attacked
shipping in the Straits of Hormuz they
had attacked oil fields in Saudi Arabia
they had attacked US bases they had
attacked our embassy they had killed
Americans these ongoing attacks were
being planned and orchestrated by
sulemani our ability to deter attacks
had obviously broken down the Iranians
had been given a number of red lines and
were crossing those lines they obviously
felt that they could attack us and
continue these escalating attacks with
impunity
the general in charge of these efforts
sulemani was clearly a legitimate
military target and we had a very brief
window of time to carry out the attack
when he arrived in Baghdad to plan and
orchestrate follow-up attacks on
American interests in American people
personnel so this was a legitimate act
of self-defense for because it disrupted
ongoing attacks that were being
conducted a campaign against the
Americans and it reestablished
deterrence it responded to attacks that
had been already committed our purpose
and our expectation was not to trigger a
broader conflict or that events would
spin out of control on the contrary we
believed that the strike would restore
deterrence and help avoid a continuing
upward spiral of the violence two
questions one on topic in law
the investigation in identify any
betting issues that could have led to
the prevention of the attack anything
that could have been noticed pass along
to authorities that would have indicated
an attack was coming that that the
vetting should be improved of these
candidates I wouldn't suggest or
speculate that improved vetting would
necessarily have prevented this
particular event but I do think it's
clear and I think the Department the
Department of Defense agrees that we
have to improve our vetting procedures
and they are in the process of doing
that the students are here the pilots
are here and then if I could just do a
quick follow-up in terms of the vetting
about doing it before they come to the
United States question did you into the
evidence regarding thorough soleimani
see any evidence of a specific imminent
threat or was it more generic in terms
of what had been done and what was
generally thought that that was being
played I'm not gonna get into the
specific the specific intelligence I
believe there was intelligence of
imminent attack but I I do believe that
this concept of imminence is something
of a red herring I think when you're
dealing with a situation where you
already have a tax under way you have a
you you know there is a campaign that
involves repeated attacks on American
targets I don't think there's a
requirement frankly for you know knowing
the exact time and place of the next
attack and that certainly was the
position of the Obama administration
when it droned leaders of terrorist
organizations yes to questions about
Apple quick questions what is Apple
willing to do here you said nothing
subjective
what are they willing to do here if the
company's willing do anything at all I
don't know what they're willing to do
second question how big of a problem is
this on a larger scale for for people at
home to understand you know the battle
in between technology companies and law
enforcement and what they're dealing
with is this something you've seen a lot
or some of your associates have been
dealing with for a long time yeah we're
seeing an increasing number of these
cases and it involves not only data at
rest that is data stored in devices as
is the case here but also data in motion
that is intercepted communications that
were unable to decrypt even though we
know those communications involve the
planning of you know deadly attacks or
you know cartel activity or the
exploitation of children and it's
becoming a grave problem yes if you had
one more question
Attorney General bar where did the
consultations begin with the
administration over the strike and we
general Soleimani step has the threat
from this bullet to target inside the
United States Benzino I'm not going to
discuss you know the details of or the
timeline of consultations and the second
part of your question had to do with
what general Soleimani of death has the
threat from his bullet targets inside
the United States and diminish I'm not
gonna speculate about that on the on the
to to quick questions on the Salomon
Salamone attack did you give any special
considered consideration to the fact
that he was the senior official of
another government that he was a general
of the of Iran and um he was a head of
terrorist organization was there any
special consideration given that he was
also a senior official well military
targets are appropriate legitimate
targets vetting of other people inside
the u.s. training with the US military
or their broader concerns that it wasn't
just limited to what happened in
Pensacola that there might be a more
systemic issue I don't think there's any
indication of that but I'm sure that
when the Department of Defense considers
its vetting process that'll probably
have implications beyond the kingdom the
FBI had exhausted all of his effort
everything available including private
companies to try to get into these phone
they've done everything they can and uh
now just depended upon Apple that what
you guys are saying yeah but I would
also hasten to add that we don't want to
get into a world where you know we have
to spend months and even years
exhausting efforts when lives are in the
balance we should be able to get in once
we have a have a warrant that
establishes that criminal activity is
probably under way thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
there's definitely some men who feel
that it's not fair that we're only
aggregating women's reviews and I say to
them you know go make dick pics I don't
know
[Music]
as this award season is showing us women
are still fighting for recognition from
Hollywood two years after this and here
are the all-male nominees but despite
several studies showing that women have
made progress both on and off the screen
Miranda Bailey saw one issue that's
still needed addressing I noticed the
difference between the way men critics
and female critics wrote about a project
not just whether they scored it the same
or liked it the same but just in the
tone it's unfortunate you can go out and
look at the masthead of any large
website and see that there's a lot
missing and there's a lot there's a lot
more inclusion that could be had then I
found out that at that time that 78% of
the men on Rotten Tomatoes we're men and
then I found out that 83% of the top
critics were men and I thought to myself
well how are we supposed to know what
audiences really want if the people who
are telling them what to buy are men I
couldn't like find like one place where
I could go to be like oh well what're
what are all the girls thinking and so
cherry-picks was born cherry-picks takes
reviews that are published by females
and aggregates them we designed
different scoring systems which is a
bowl of cherries which is the best movie
ever really don't miss it go see it
tutors which is a great score definitely
go out buy a ticket one cherry which is
like yeah it's pretty good catch it from
your couch and then there's the pits
which is like don't bother I found that
a lot of our films don't get the pits
it's not really good or bad it's not a
splat or go see it
the thing about the turn books that I
like is women being allowed to be
opinionated and honest I
I went to can this year and I saw some
stuff that was like this is questionable
it made me see the need for inclusion
and how we need the different opinions
there are films that are there that are
for us for women about women there are a
lot of films that are for black people
about black those people should be the
ones to also be able to review those
films and get their perspective and I
think that that's important that people
see varied ideas at the beginning for me
it's all about the more perspectives
that we have out there watching films
and critiquing films and saying that
they are audience members and the more
opportunities that is for the filmmakers
that are women or women of color or
non-binary to be able to make movies
some criticism needs to and all
criticism videogame criticism music
criticism the audience's need to be
reflected within the critic society
people see art through different lenses
and we just want to show all of the
different lenses that are out there
[Music]
I get the question all the time why are
you a men's rights advocate as a woman
right that's just weird
why wouldn't I if I see something wrong
and I can help put it right why wouldn't
I do that do you ask male feminists you
know why do you care about women why are
you asking a woman why do you care about
men I'm here at the International
Conference for men's issues this
conference cut